kelly ripa told me this actually you
think
oh my god that was so great or you think
oh my god that was so bad it's never
as amazing as you thought it was and
it's never as bad as you thought it was
and the other thing is you have to do it
all again tomorrow
so it's a constant growth so you're
measured not
by show but by the whole cumulative
experience or the vibe that you're
giving people you know
i think i'm really bad at the rear view
mirror in life i'll make a decision and
then
ask myself 20 times over was it the
right one but i don't have a big review
mirror when it comes to work
i'm much more about the next thing oh
good that's a really healthy vibe
i just have such positive feelings about
your show because
i think we as a nation are in a place
where we're looking for an escape and
we're looking for good news
or positivity and you're a good news
positive lady that a lot of people love
and connect with and so
i think for that reason this is going to
be
this is going to go well i'm utterly
flawed too
well that's good but that's why we
relate to you also you know we've
seen you since you were gertie we've
seen you on your
highs and on your lows you know but we
want to run up to the pitcher's mound
and kiss you uh because you've never
been kissed
you know
you